checkmating very important part of the
game
now the stronger you get the more likely
it is that your opponent will castle
alright so instead of checkmating a king
that's in the center of the board a lot
of times we're dealing with checkmating
a castle king right very typical
situation is one like this now
we're white in this position the
material is equal but one side has a big
advantage which side has a big advantage
here yeah why that's part of it
another thing is what can you tell me
about black's pieces here they're
crowded up and they're also not doing
what they're not defending the king side
right so this King has no defenders on
it right even though it's good that
these pawns are helping protect usually
we want a piece or two to protect as
well right
like typically we would have at least a
knight on f6 right and that would do a
really good job of keeping the Queen out
and defending 8:7 right now all of our
pieces are off to the side so if you are
white how would you start trying to
create checkmating threats Charlie
95 one way to start what's another way
to start early yeah Bishop t32 another
way max what were you thinking
but searching for is a good idea to I I
like I like all of these moves you guys
are suggesting but I do like one better
than the others so let's take a vote
how many people here we've got three
candidates here right and chess it's
really important to think of your
candidate moves and what we do is we
think about the moves that look pretty
appealing and then we examine what our
opponent might do against all of them
then we pick based on what we think the
final position will be for all those
different possibilities right it's hard
to do but you get a lot better by doing
it so here are three possible moves or
candidate moves Bishop d3 Bishop c4 and
95 so take a minute and tell me we'll
vote and see which one gets the most
votes so Knight g5 Bishop here and
Bishop here those are our three moves
okay how many people will play Knight to
g5 raise your hand all right we've got
one two three four five votes 495 how
many people play Bishop d3 raise your
head we've got one two three four five
six seven eight we've got about eight
votes for Bishop d3 and how about Bishop
c4 no votes for Bishop just one okay and
then a lot of people who have stained
from voting all right so I like I like
all these moves but Bishop d3 is very
direct I like that move the best we are
threatening checkmate in one where is a
checkmate in one that were threatening
air Blayne h7 with what right with the
queen we take what the bishop it
wouldn't be made so queen h7 checkmate
is our threat now how would black try to
defend against it
Jonathan g6 what's the other possibility
so h6 r g6 or the two possibilities to
defend against checkmate here right now
suppose they play h6 what would you do
now as white yeah
Queen f5 okay that's what you meant
right queen fi is possible in that way
don't black only one move here now one
move to stop mating Gus yeah
g60 only move this not mating did
anybody have another idea besides Queen
f5 Jonathan okay so that's great so you
came up with the move [ __ ] it takes
eight chicks without fully analyzing it
I bet I bet you just had a feeling that
was going to be great right you didn't
analyze it to checkmate did you now
that's fine in this position because
after Bishop takes h6 now that gives up
a bishop right but after Ponte to h6
Queen takes h6 Jonathan got to this
position and said there was just no way
black and defend against this position
right now now normally that's a bad
thing to do should always analyze to
checkmate but there are some exceptions
and this is an exception where it's just
very clear that your attack is
overwhelming right I mean your friend
ain't checkmate Oh on right what's your
tuck made of one threat max but it's not
going to be enough like you can you can
defend against checkmate in one first of
all what's checkmate ooh one threat
let's go there first yes can you remind
me your name Gary Anya Queen h7 is a
maiden one threat so first of all
there's not that many ways to defend
against it if you play something like
this this is insufficient why how can
white mate here there's two ways
actually once in important patterns I'm
going to show you the slow and the long
way there's one that is just made and
two but there's one that's a pattern
that we need to go over so somebody you
want to show me the law the short way
and somebody can show me the long way
what's the short way short way to
checkmate
maybe see check me into I'm going to
yeah over there
no we want it to be totally forcing here
we have a totally forcing way to
checkmate yeah I'm that will lead to
checkmate too but we have a more forcing
way yes Alessia that's good that's not
the SH that's not the short way Jonathan
queen h7 is the shortest checkmate
because after kf8 now Queen H a is me
because of Y what's stopping this king
from coming out here yeah mm-hmm exactly
the what Connie one is cutting off the
king from here so Queen H eight is just
mating very good now of course it's
normally good just to pick the quickest
checkmate that's what i always recommend
but here there is an important check
mating pattern that takes a little bit
longer so i would like to look at that
as well didn't anybody see an
alternative way to force checkmate here
like for instance suppose it's a
different position like we play rook e1
we take recapture works here and now
maybe you don't want to play queen h7
anymore because after King f8 Queen h8
it's not mate right see that that
wouldn't be checkmate now I'm not saying
it's not good for white because after
we're q1 check this looks pretty good
too right but in that case you might
want to find a quicker mate or a quicker
cleaner win so how does white mate now
this is an important pattern that you
should memorize wait to move I'll give
you guys actually a minute for this
and this is the kind of thing where if
you've seen it before you've seen it a
few times you should be able to find the
checkmate instantly even though it's
like four moves deep whereas if you've
ever seen it it will it will make you
will take you some time and that's why
we study checkmates at home so that when
we see them on the board we can see it
instantly here you had a couple answer
is yes in the red short what's her name
again
avi Oh Joseph okay what's the first move
Bishop h7 excellent now this doesn't
look at first like the best move because
it's blocking or Queen from the attack
but now after King to h8 you have a
really smart maneuver here that creates
a checkmating attack so I know that
we've got a couple people who got it I
think I think Jonathan and Charlie both
have it but I'm going to give people a
little bit longer to find it on your own
because if you find it on your own then
your chances are remembering it or a lot
higher in general you should remember
that if you have somebody show you
something that's that's sometimes that's
okay because you've been working at it
for a while but it's always going to be
more instructive if you try it yourself
and go through the motions of figuring
it out so that's what you should attempt
max 95 is not right now it's a good
instinct to get another piece into the
attack that's a great instinct and I'm
sure 95 is crushing but we have a forced
mate in uh in three more moves so we
always we always are prioritizing
getting fourth checkmate right yeah
Queen to f6 is not the fastest way
although actually that does win that's a
good idea to Queen f6 King it and now
after King h7 what's your idea you do it
it is kind of it's kind of it's less
typical but that is a winning
checkmating idea as well so queen f
queen up after Queen f6 check King h7
what would you do after Queen to f6
check which is a good idea does win
after King h7 now how would you finish
this off this is just not as typical of
the pattern but it's also definitely a
force to check mating variation yeah now
after 95 when the king goes back to g8
what were you going to do let him finish
and then I'll go to you next you know 95
q g8 try to visualize that where are we
after 95 check King goes back to g8 then
what would you do exactly and then after
King 88
very good okay see that those of you who
are in my last class we were doing more
basic versions of this but we were
always seeing this important checkmate
with the Queen right against the king
defended by a piece so that was
excellent very good that is not as
typical of a pattern of what I'm looking
for but it goes to show how overwhelming
White's position is that he has so many
different ways to create mate and that's
why of course in addition to castling
you also want to leave some defenders
over in the castle position but there's
a more typical pattern that I would like
us all to memorize as well do you see
the other way to checkmate here so he's
using the knight but there's a way to
use another piece to try to pinpoint
black that's not the rook actually it's
not the rook Charlie what were you
thinking Bishop g6 is a very typical
pattern here excellent now after Bishop
d6 check notice that you're also turning
this pawn right here and then after King
to g8 what can wait do ah because it's a
discovered check right so notice when
your Bishop moves its discovering check
on the King right and then after came
here now how does white finish them off
yeah do you see see how white finishes
off very similar to his variation but
now instead of using the knight we're
using the bishop what is he GCM how can
white finish you off so if we plead here
that would just be repeating the
position if we repeat them position
three times in chess what is that it's
not a stalemate it's a draw it's a type
of draw right but it's not a stalemate
so Bishop h7 check would we want to do
that when we have such an overwhelming
position no right so instead how would
white finish black off here uh Queen g7
loses the Queen and also we want you to
raise your hand okay so try to find a
checkmate in two moves here I know you
can but let me see you ask Anne yeah any
thoughts
got it Queen h7 excellent
and notice the difference here now when
the King goes to f8 instead of playing
Queen h8 allowing you to escape we can
go where Queen takes f7 right so see how
that was very similar to the checkmate
over here except now the Queen is
defended by the bishop instead of the
night these checkmates they keep coming
up right now Jonathan I know you're a
very experienced you won the kid's
tournament you're playing a lot of the
adult tournaments but it took you it
took you a little bit of time to see
this pattern have you seen it before you
have seen it before okay and you know
what I mean like you say your favorite
checkmate was a smother made
that's a checkmate that you've seen it
before we'll take you about how long how
long will it take you to find it
yes whereas if you've never seen it
before we probably take you a full
minute or even more alright so exactly
this is exactly why we need this pattern
recognition you see this position you
can see this now in a few seconds as
opposed to a few minutes
that makes sense to everyone and that's
why it was so easy for Jonathan to
quickly play Bishop takes 8 6 because
you can just tell like the map here this
is math we've got 1 2 3 attackers
how many defenders do we have I would
say 0 I mean you count this pawn I don't
know if you can count this pawn I mean
this is probably the best try to play f5
here so that at least this beautiful
bishop is cut off that's got to be the
best tried to stop mating attack here
but it's and it gives the King more
space it's true so what would you try to
play here is white 2 to win minute win
the position oh there's so many wins
here actually there's one that's like
just very simple um yeah so 95 seems
like a pretty good move
I really can't knock that move but also
if you know if you want to know that you
can win material immediately you can do
all sorts of things I mean you could
even take this night off but and then
win this and then take this night off
here but no we would start with taking
this Knight but I think
you can do better than that in fact his
Bishop is just so strong 95 is got to be
totally crushing but in addition we can
also play yes and the glasses next to
Jonathan ah yes and Ricky 7 the knight
can take but of course we would love to
have our work in the game Jonathan queen
g6 and then after King h8 I mean there's
so many wins here yeah I mean this I
like I like this move bringing the work
into the game and threatening mate and
one I mean not for not for a mate and
one threatening mate in - yeah just -
yeah it looks like we need a few moves
to actually execute the checkmate but
it's totally over and also this isn't
take and then another moves Bishop here
I mean and then the only way to prevent
it is with rook f7 and then after work
at 7 you can do what I'm instead of
taking it immediately you can also just
play a White Queen g6 check first and
then then you're going to lose the whole
rock because you can't even interpolate
this so the point is is that there's
multiple multiple wins after Bishop to
h6
pawn takes a takes Queen a checks
so instead suppose they play g6 this
seems like a bit more of a stubborn idea
stopping checkmate
by using this pawn rather than the H
pawn now what would you do is white to
continue the attack and try to
checkmater upon it yeah
yeah keep them closed in perfect and now
suppose they play in this position
their position is so bad let's say they
play here now how would you continue as
white so these patterns are all very
important
max ninety-five excellent notice how
again without any protection over here
of the King it's going to be impossible
to defend eight seven properly right you
can't even do it
Queen eight seven is just coming right
so this position is now already totally
over so in order to try to prevent
checkmate white would black would have
to try something here but it doesn't
seem like very likely like for instance
maybe they'll play f6 to stop the move
Knight g5 and now what could you do
let's let's all raise our hands guys so
many winning moves here but let's just
see what you guys come up with Charlie
Bishop c4 check I like it very good and
then after King h8 pretty much I mean
you could play you could play work f7
here but then just Bishop f7 Queen eight
seven and everything is falling apart so
suppose it can go to h8 let me try
somebody else now what important
principle in attacking your opponent is
always really important to bring another
piece into the game remember we were
trying to bring the knight into the game
because I was just tackle black right
with so much coming in so black stop
that by bringing his pawn to defend the
knight but guess what that creates
another problem another Avenue for
attack for riot so how can white bring a
very powerful piece into the attack now
rook d7 right so you create that's what
happens when you're getting attacked so
brutally right you stop one problem
which was my knight coming to g5 and you
just create another problem right
that's why you need pieces to depend
right because when you depend with pawns
sometimes it works out but a lot of
times you solve one problem
create another problem that's what
happens when you're only relying on
pawns for defense so work to do seven
now threatening checkmate over here and
it looks like a really bad situation
although I did just notice that they can
play they do have an idea here that
might be kind of annoying so maybe I
wouldn't yeah this move this move here
make things a little bit more
complicated so maybe that this was not
actually the best move you know we
should have done it in a slightly
different order the best way to make
this just totally devastating is by
switching up the move order and
distracting the Queen momentarily
so Ruth d7 is just so crushing if it's
not for Bishop takes H to check after
which the situation becomes more
complicated listen it's still pretty
good for right because like so we could
just take with the knight and then after
Queen takes rook Bishop takes and it
still looks like there's going to be
some attacking chances here for Wyatt
we've got we basically have two pieces
for a rock and a nice attack but that's
not good enough for me I'd rather I'd
rather make them resign so an even
better way to try to finish the game
yeah exactly Bishop takes 86 first and
then after Queen takes a6 now after work
d7 there are no tricks and this rook is
just dominant right there's no way to
prevent Queen takes h7
not even for a move right I mean well
that's it all right
rook to f7 and now and now there's no
there's no more moves except can anybody
find a way to prolong the move one more
move okay just in case your opponent's
lag is about to fall yeah yeah I'm
calling on you yes
- really oh yeah you're right of course
yeah yeah yeah - but you have to do it
in the right move order I think to get
away with - you might only be able to do
one I think you can actually do only do
one there are two opt-ins yeah okay but
but you're saying you could play Bishop
takes h2 or you could play you can just
play Queen f1 yeah and now that prolongs
a game one moves yes you got some ICC or
chess accomplished players who know how
to prolong the game for just to mover -
in case your opponent's about to lose on
time all right so what we learn here is
it's really important not only to castle
but to keep some defenders around your
castle position as well right and the
other thing that you need to know is
when your opponent does threaten this
type of checkmate be careful because yes
sometimes you have to play G six or
eight six but there are the kind of down
downsides to both moves as well in the
case of h6 the downside was that it
became a target for the sacrifice right
in the case of g6 what was the downside
this one well it opens up this nice to
h6 Square for the Queen to rest and then
we really you're not going to be able to
get the Queen away I mean basically what
black would love to do here if you have
the coordination in this night war and
hanging is to play Queen here right
generally when you're getting attacked
so much you really want to figure out
how to trade Queens but because that's
so impossible for black to actually do
there's so many steps that would have to
occur first this position just looks
totally losing for a black good job guys
so every every attacking position you
know you got to look out for this stuff
now in this position if it was white to
move what would you do this is an
example of how important it is when
you're black - notice these things
coming up and try to trade Queens if you
can or find other clever ways to defend
so here what would you do if White
move yeah
no Queen h4 is too slow you need to be
even faster Queen h4 you know is one a
little bit too slow
max Queen h6 yes you need to try to
threaten checkmate immediately it's
actually blacks move so I'll just make a
move and then after Queen eight-six how
does black defend against this threat of
Queen g7 mate max
how do we defend against a threat of
Queen g7 made ya queen c3 does that work
do we can just what can wait to hear
what we can do we can just check me in
one move anyway right
so basically this is an example of weak
dark squares that's another reason why a
lot of times you don't want to play this
move g6 because sometimes you can get
these types of ugly mating situations
now what if it's black smooth come up
with some ideas to defend against
checkmate here is black that's an
important skill right not only trying to
get checkmate yourself but figuring out
how to stop checkmate so suppose you're
black here what would you do there's a
couple ways to try to defend against
checkmate so your opponent wants to come
here and then meet you what do you do to
make it not so yes
I'm though uh what's that yeah I was
calling on you hmm okay you were just
out grabbing something alright charlie
okay working six is one idea oh sorry I
played a move okay so Ricky six is one
idea what were you thinking Jonathan
were you thinking your marquee six -
okay max were you thinking something
else huh
oh you were thinking you were seasick so
all these ideas are based on trying to
hit this Bishop Queen e6 is another one
where you're they're trying to hit this
Bishop so that after Queen f-86 you can
just simply recapture the bishop right
and then black would be winning there's
one other idea which is kind of thematic
it's probably not quite as strong but
yeah yeah I like this kind of idea of
Queen a3 the only problem with it is
White has a kind of clever move here but
I like the idea you're trying to say
that after Queen eight six I'm going to
see if somebody else can configure this
out why is this position so different
after Queen two eight six what can black
do now to prevent the checkmate on g7
what Square can this Queen move to
hmm that's right very good so Queen FA
stops checkmate and what's even better
than just stopping checkmate is when
you're getting attacked how do you feel
about Queen Fried's
when your opponent did somebody say
awesome haha yeah definitely when you're
trying when you're getting attacked
usually you're really excited about
Queen trades why is that yeah yeah
because it's harder to checkmate without
Queens on the board right in fact a lot
of times when there are no Queens on the
board we call that what it means that
it's the it means that it's the endgame
right
when Queens are off the board Jonathan
did you want to add something yes
exactly because the endgame is actually
technically not defined by Queens off
the board they technically define the
endgame as a position where the King is
no longer under immediate attack of
checkmate right so there are positions
where they call them queenless middle
games in which the pieces are so strong
that the check that king can still get
checkmated in the middle of the board
but it's rare
normally no Queen no mating attack until
you promote a pawn and make another
Queen right so when you're getting
attacked and your king is unsafe look
for ways to trade Queens and this is an
example of that yes question you can
check me with two bishops versa King yes
but that's a two bishops verse alone
King if you have two bishops in your
opponent has some pieces usually you
don't have any kind of checkmating
attack see what I'm saying
so that's the difference alright guys I
am going to you guys did a really good
job today I'm going to let you guys I'm
have a chance to play amongst each other
maybe warm up raise your hand if you're
playing at 2:30 in the tournament so
give you give you a chance for a little
warm-up here